pour retrait du plan de restructuration
démission du président d'air france les
événements se sont donc précipités hier
soir qu'il faut dire que la grève qui
dure depuis plus d'une semaine c'était
encore durci pendant le week-end eve
mettait les événements pas de
déclaration bernard attali a choisi la
voix discrète d'un simple communiqué
pour annoncer sa démission de la
présidence d'air france
un communiqué sous forme de message aux
personnels de la compagnie les pouvoirs
publics dit il ayant décidé de retirer
le programme de retour à l'équilibré que
je considère comme indispensable à la
survie de l'entreprise
j'ai présenté ma démission au
gouvernement une demi-heure auparavant
le ministre des transports bernard
bosson déclaré qu'air france avait
besoin d'un autre plan social que celui
en cours actuellement
il faut changer clan bâtir un autre
autrement et d'autres méthodes et dans
le dialogue dans l'entreprise à nouveau
plan demande des mois de travail de
préparation et de dialogue ce n'est pas
du tout quelque chose qui peut se faire
en quelques semaines il faut au minimum
trois mois pour pouvoir garantir un
travail sérieux et un dialogue
approfondi dans l'entreprise le ministre
a ajouté que les 4000 suppressions
d'emplois sont incontournables et qu'il
n'y aurait selon lui aucun licenciement
sec
le retrait du plan social et la
démission de bernard attali ces deux
nouvelles tombes dont treize jours après
le début du conflit
commencée le 12 octobre dans le cadre de
la journée d'action nationale cgt fo
partie des secteurs fret et maintenance
de la compagnie le conflit s'était durci
la semaine dernière occupation des
pistes par les grévistes
blocage du trafic aérien affrontements
avec les crs
vendredi soir les propositions du
ministère des transports pour aménager
le plan était rejetée la semaine qui
commence s'annonçait comme une nouvelle
zone de turbulences pour demain
notamment le syndicat des pilotes de
ligne avait à son tour appelé à la grève
ainsi que les syndicats d'air inter et
d'aéroports de paris
une nouvelle montée de tension que le
gouvernement a voulu désamorcer hier
soir
le gouvernement joue donc la carte de la
paix sociale comme on dit